then Jimmy is anticipating the drive  tries to beat him to the spot right  shoulder in that's close Mike da ha that  is close now players have to be  separated looked like it was just joying  as they were walking up the court and  see the officials and if they're gonna  hand outs of double technicals you know  look like Butler and Griffin were fine  just going back and forth Langston  Galloway sticking up for his teammate  that Butler took exception to so much  ado about nothing  again that's just joined  [Applause]  [Music]  though officials quickly getting yeah  that's what it is  by the way things have been called the  last several years in the NBA have a  feeling that's gonna be fall right